I don't want to I don't want to believe
[ __ ] if it if it doesn't hurt me I it
shouldn't be such a big deal
I want to know right now on this podcast
who is running this country there's a
bunch of different factions that you
call the government history science
education energy everything has always
been controlled by the government since
day one
look at the time illegal aliens in the
work face as recommended by the
Commission headed by former
congresswoman Barbara Jordan if you look
into the experiments to prove that the
earth is spinning all of them failed
look into it what do you do you just
have this if you look into it in you and
you have proof that it is round instead
of going oh some scientists figure it
out somebody figured it out
somebody figured out but you figure it
out you try to figure it out though no
because when they look into it it's
common sense and when you look into it
[Music]